[Music]
NBC aired a live version of The Sound of
Music last week starring Carrie
Underwood now sound of music that's one
of my favorite musicals but I'm just not
sure this new production was up to snuff
take a look welcome back it was
everything there's nothing like being
your own boss and my customers are
really liking your flat rate shipping
FedEx one rate really makes my life
easier
okay I'm sorry we just stop it and stop
stop stop
Jeff what was that an ad for FedEx yeah
I know it was an ad for FedEx what's it
doing in the middle of our show mistress
fifteen seconds that's how we do it
online you have to watch an ad before
you see the clip yeah Jeff we've been
through this before
no 15-second ads in the middle of the
show okay got it all right sorry anyway
as I was saying the live sound of music
musical wasn't really all that exciting
FedEx
Jeff vinick's problem fedex yes there's
a problem I told you no ads during the
show FedEx these are shorter FedEx
there's still ads FedEx okay fine no
more ads starting tomorrow
FedEx no no more ads starting right now
FedEx got it good great
okay apologize now anyway the live sound
of music the prof Cinnabon Jeff Cinnabon
what now Cinnabon
now it says Cinnabon Cinnabon
that's because it's an ad for Cinnabon
Cinnabon I told you no ads Cinnabon I
thought you meant no FedEx ads Cinnabon
that's not the point
Cinnabon it's a food Cinnabon
I know it's a food Cinnabon unlike FedEx
which is a package delivery service
thanks yeah stop it I know the
difference I don't care what product is
for I don't want to see another ad on
the TV screen okay thanks got it okay
good
anyway NBC's live sound of music
broadcasting my thanks Jeff what are you
doing it wasn't on the screen it was on
the backdrop all right look
okay whatever all right we got a great
show tonight we're thrilled hip-hop
superstar Snoop Dogg is on the show
Mike Birbiglia comedian Mike Birbiglia
is here I've got him
we fit gasps seven days of funk
featuring Snoop Zilla and Dame funk yeah
and we have a lot more show coming up
we'll be right back after this important
message from amazon.com amazon.com
delivering Cinnabon by FedEx for the hub
[Applause]